hey everyone we are back at witty women
in technology International and we are
now sitting down with Lauren Maffeo hi
thanks for having me thank you for
coming on to the show thanks it's a
pleasure and we are gonna talk about get
app yep we're going to talk about the
importance of enterprise and
understanding what all these different
software's are doing and which ones are
awesome which ones are not so awesome
because there's so many of them and
you're like the TripAdvisor for sass
right for surfer enterprise software
getup is yes the idea behind get app is
that if you're a smaller mid-sized
business owner and you need HR software
to manage your team the idea it would
get up is that you would go to get app
comm you would read LinkedIn verified
reviews of different cloud HR software
tools you would read reviews that people
have left of those products and then you
can filter to get the features you need
to find tools that support which
operating system you prefer and once you
filter for what you need out of software
and then read reviews the ideas that you
would use get app to compare products
and ultimately find the best HR software
for your business is it specifically for
HR software HR is one of many markets so
actually as an analyst I cover project
management software and to a smaller
extent extent accounting software but we
have actually hundreds of categories of
software not only on get app calm but on
get apps sister companies kaptara and
software advice those three sites all
help small and midsize business owners
choose the right software for their
businesses and we're all part of Gartner
which is a global research and advisory
firm for the enterprise and then within
Gartner and specifically within Gartner
research the three of us are in a
business unit that supports the SMB
space yep okay so Gartner is the parent
and has the large research and advisory
for enterprise and then there's the
three
the three companies kind of in the
umbrella of Gartner that one owns get
app and a software advice and what was
the other one
kaptara kaptara and so with get app you
CD you gave these like verticals you
were with that you were looking at
accounting and project management ones
which are actually both really important
especially p.m. because project
management is basically the way that you
can push out what you're trying to build
most effectively into existence and be
able to effectively use time which is
the most valuable thing that's huge and
then you were you said accounting and
what was the other one we were talking
about well so HR is the hypothetical
example that I gave and then within all
three of those sister sites we have
research analysts who cover different
priority markets that are unique to what
they cover so I don't actually cover HR
software but that's where the project
management software coverage and
accounting software coverage comes in
that's what I cover so give us some
insight into what howhow how would our
things even analyze you said there's
like a LinkedIn verified profile so once
I log in to get up with my LinkedIn that
I'm verified and then I can make
comments on people on different software
enterprise software with my thoughts on
how I've had using it how do you know
that I've used it and how do you rank
how what is it like a five-star ranking
and then it's like an overall like 400
people I've ranked the software it's
average as four and a half stars is that
kind of what it's like so there are
averages in terms of a product's average
rating based on what users say and then
the users are responsible for writing
pros and cons of the tools that they are
reviewing and those reviews are attached
to their LinkedIn profile so they there
is a name attached to the review for
accountability in order to make sure
that those reviews are correct and
that's something that is hugely
important to us because we know how
important software reviews are when
people are making a big decision like
buying software because it's it's
probably hopefully a one-time purchase
that you won't have to
again because shopping for software is
very expensive and laborious and we know
that reviews play an important role in
that software buying journey so it's
very important to us to make sure that
those reviews have high quality and that
people can trust them because we live in
an age where people when they're buying
software they want to do a substantial
amount of their own research before they
ever actually talk to a vendor and so we
really try to facilitate that process
and make it as seamless as we can
okay so there's two parties at play here
there's both the clients that are
looking for enterprise software to
purchase and then there's the enterprise
software companies that are looking to
provide awesome enterprise software so
then what are kind of the what would an
enterprise software manufacturer creator
what would they want to build out in
their vertical I mean then there's
different verticals there's a Chargers
accounting there's all these different
verticals that we were just talking
about but how can they best build out
something that I guess what have you
seen for the companies that have
submitted to get app and that are being
reviewed on there what's the best user
experience for for their for their
platform as well as the people coming in
that are their clients when we as
analysts read user reviews of software
products regardless of which market
we're covering two big themes come up
one is ease-of-use and the second is
strong customer service and so whether
you're using a more technical tool or
you're using something that is used to
manage email marketing regardless we
find that those are the two key things
that people want from software and that
those are especially important they
sound really basic but it's actually not
unheard of for people to buy software
that for example is too big for their
needs and so that's a big part of what
we do as analysts is helping the readers
choose what tool they need based on what
their business needs are because as an
example if you are a freelancer and you
need
a great billing product you probably
don't need to a tool with more features
than that especially because you're
going to pay more and so from the
software vendor side ease of use and
strong customer service are both really
important and also on that note having a
clean interface is important if people
can't easily navigate the software
they're going to get frustrated really
quickly and I listen to the use of use
yeah exactly in that and I'm in that
category as well I mean even covering
software myself one would hope I'd have
more patience to go through the nav and
and do all of that but but I it's just
natural that if you can't find something
within a couple of seconds you're you
just your brain you know like a light
bulb goes off and you get frustrated and
so those are the two things that we see
repeatedly as either pros or cons for
vendors and so I think those two things
have to be well done before you move on
to building out more extensive feature
sets for your customers yeah it's almost
like for every single software company
that's tuning in that's building out SAS
their software as a service the ease of
use and also the customer service or
support needs to be ironed out first in
your MVP and especially the simplicity
of use just the sheer like you can't
have a customer that is trying to find
something that can't find something like
it's got to be really simple and easy
otherwise that we've all felt at that
feeling and then you're like even after
just a couple seconds you're giving up
because you're like screw it
it's not easy enough right moving on yes
and those are market agnostic
recommendations but something else I
will say is that it's important to know
how users are using your product and why
they're using it and product project
management software is a great example
of that because regardless of whether
you have a software team that's working
on more technical projects or you have a
digital team and a creative agency that
needs project management software we
have found a get up doing research
that the vast majority of teams use
project management software because they
want to collaborate more effectively so
it's not necessarily going into the
weeds it certainly there are products
that fulfill that need of going into the
weeds but it goes back to the bigger
reason why people are using the tool and
we find that even when you have teams
using a tool like JIRA for example which
is built for more technical project
teams the main reason they use it in the
main benefit they see by and large is
because they want to collaborate more
effectively with their project teams and
so if you know as the vendor that the
main reason people are using your
product is to communicate more clearly
and to collaborate better then you can
start building out feature sets that are
more aligned with what your users need
from the product yep
yep getting a constant feedback loop
from your customers back to the
engineers and designers and then also I
feel like with project management
software this is probably one of the
most important software tools for
companies is project management software
it is yeah yeah and I mean I'm biased
because I cover that market but it but
it is hugely important because anything
can be a project in theory and I mean in
in the case of a very small business
your business is probably the project
and you're gonna have key milestones and
deliverables and you would have a
backlog and then you would use maybe a
methodology like agile to fulfill
sprints and take things out of the
backlog so it's so choosing the right
project management software is hugely
important if it's something you need and
so and there's a lot of nuance there
especially because the discipline of
project management has changed so much
it's it has its roots really in software
and developing software projects but we
see today that project management role
is having much bigger business impact
than before and you I mean I think the
rise of agile is he is a big example of
that because agile
again it's a methodology that has its
roots and software development but now
you see it being used in businesses of
all sizes and in companies that do work
that is not related to software projects
and software development and so what are
they using it for I think they're using
it by and large as a way to do more work
faster so the whole idea behind agile is
that you work in Sprint's that are
shorter and ideally there's an AK wick
feedback loop which empowers you to put
more work out there faster and so I
think that idea is appealing to two
people especially small businesses and
there are restraints in terms of who
agile is best for and instances where it
doesn't work as well it does tend to
work really well if you have a small
team that can respond to feedback
quickly and there are some hindrances
we've heard from some people on project
teams in either a project management or
PMO role that they don't like the daily
stand-ups for example and they think
that they take time away from building
and so I'm there is some truth to that
daily stand up yeah in agile yes so part
of agile invited does involve having a
daily stand up with your team where you
check in with each other and everybody
gets on the same page about status
updates before you go back to doing the
work and so sometimes that doesn't align
with how certain people on project teams
are certain project leaders like to work
but again I think it goes back to a main
reason why people use project management
software which is to communicate and
collaborate more effectively because
it's it's so easy these days to just get
into the weeds of what you're doing
without seeing the bigger picture so
hopefully you would use project
management and project management
software to get that big picture I think
there's also an important role in just
talking to the team just in general just
emotional intelligence and being able to
show people that you actually care about
them and that you're wanting to build a
relationship with them as you go through
this and
like you know they care about you care
about you care about what they care
about you have a same value or same
ethic and if you don't then you like to
talk about it and try and like figure
out all the variables about it but then
that sort of relationship rather than
just like weather and sports and all the
other stuff it ties people closer
together having that first of the two so
I can see why also people are like no
just get the work done so agile what so
give me another example of an of an
industry besides software though that
like people would think that like PM
tools are being used in I wrote a
research report not that long ago forget
app on the use of project management
software among creative teams so these
would be people within ad agencies for
example like Ogilvy who are using
project management software to visualize
their campaigns see the big picture of
for example a campaign and then all of
the steps that would have to be
completed before it goes live and also
using the project management staff
software with stakeholders at agent ad
work and creative work is another line
of work where there are a lot of
stakeholders involved in stakeholder
management is a key skill within project
management and so we did some research a
few months ago to learn who on creative
teams was using project management
software and what they were using it for
and again we did see that they were
largely using it for collaboration and
communication and also in creative
industries it's very important to
visualize your work and so that's an
example of where a methodology like
Kanban and perhaps a project management
software tool like Trello would be
perhaps a good fit and so again it goes
back to what you need it for the
software wit and that should play a key
role in what you look for when you're
purchasing it so if you need to
visualize the work and you want to see
it in a board framework then using a
tool like Trello which is inspired by
Kanban would probably be a good fit if
you are primarily looking for tasks
management and delegation that's where a
tool like asana might be a good fit if
you want to manage software development
projects something like JIRA would be a
good fit and so it really goes back to
understanding what you need the software
for because JIRA is a fabulous tool but
it's probably not the best software
choice if you are a project manager in a
ad agency yeah it's a JIRA for software
development and then Trello for over
little aboard kind of like the notes
that you're pushing along to get done
and then asana for what was asana for
that would that is odda has many
different use cases but it's it excels
really a task management and in
designate designation and so it could
it's a good fit if it goes to a lot of a
lot of software has task management it's
a it's a very essential feature within
software so you're gonna find that in
many different tools that you look for
and it's important that thought project
management software has task management
features what else is really important
for us to know about get app yeah I
think what's important to know is that
we are ideally a resource to not just
help small business owners choose
software when they need it but also to
be a space that will top tell small and
midsize business owners what they need
to know about emerging technologies and
how they impact small businesses so we
as analysts cover for example trends in
many different verticals including
marketing and sales and accounting
specifically we talked about how
emerging technologies play a role in
what small and midsize business owners
do so as one example just got a
certificate from MIT an AI yeah oh
that's that's also something that SMBs
are really looking at right now they are
so I got a certificate in AI for
business strategy from MIT Sloan which
was a fantastic course that I highly
recommend if viewers are interested in
it it was really great because you learn
about machine learning naturally
which processing and robotics so the
course focuses on those three specific
AI technologies that in itself is
important because we talk about AI as
this monolithic thing when there's so
much nuance to the different
technologies within it and so it focuses
on those three technologies and then
gives an overview of what they do but
then the core focus of the course is
choose learning how to implement those
technologies within businesses for them
to solve problems so for example you
could use robotics to standardize the
customer experience by hopefully
guaranteeing that customers will receive
something by a certain date and time and
that and that impacts your
differentiation strategy because then
you could do something that your
competitors can't do and so then when
you get into the small and mid-sized
business market it gets challenging
because a lot of these technologies do
carry high risk and then they also can
be expensive to implement and so a lot
of times those aren't necessarily
realistic for small and midsize business
owners who are really short on budget
but we also do know from research we've
done that small and midsize businesses
are already using these technologies
today so as one example we recently
surveyed close to 700 small and
mid-sized business owners in the US and
asked them different questions related
to emerging technologies within the
construction segment of that group we
talked to 118 SMB construction owners
and we were surprised to learn that one
in three of them said that they're
either using a I am machine learning now
or they plan to within the next one to
two years know an additional one in five
said that group said that they have no
plans to even look at it which so there
is a gap there but then we did a little
more digging into what does that look
like what does AI in construction
management look like today and we found
two really surprising things one is that
there are already autonomous bricklayers
and bulldozers being used by some
construction sites today so know already
Campbell fat who is a former Google and
founded a company called built robotics
which does supply autonomous
construction products like bulldozers
and so he has been doing something a
little more sketchy to be autonomous a
bulldozer
so he's been getting well he's been
getting in VC investment so someone
likes the idea and bricklaying to makes
sense that's a repetitive task yeah as
long this is properly placed makes sense
and the thing about the thing I will say
about the bulldozer is that it sounds
very risky but actually where we're at
with robotics today and this goes into
self-driving cars where we're at with
the technology today those sorts of
autonomous vehicles will do well in
highly controlled environments so for
example if you have a golf cart and you
want to use an autonomous golf cart to
ride around a nursing home and do
different things there are actually
several use cases where that sort of
autonomous golf cart performs well
because again it's a highly controlled
environment it's not going very quickly
you can program certain rules into it
and it's going to follow those rules now
the challenge is when you start adding
external variables ai isn't really good
at understanding nuance yet and so you
introduce things like bad weather and
autonomous vehicles don't perform as
well so that's something to to keep in
mind
ai sensors at this stage don't recognize
things like heavy rain thunder blizzards
and so then that does present a safety
risk and so going back to a I in
construction you have these autonomous
products and then there's a tendency for
the media to hype people up thinking
that they're going to get replaced by
robots and the other interesting aspect
of this is that when we asked small and
mid-sized business construction owners
what their biggest challenge is 45% said
that hiring the right people is their
biggest challenge and then and then 35%
said that implementing the right
technologies was their challenge as
and they were allowed to choose more
than one challenge so those were the two
big ones and so you could be tempted to
think that because kids some of
construction management is being
automated that it's a threat to jobs but
actually growth construction management
job growth is actually well above
average in the US and there has been an
increased amount of investment into the
sector and a lot of jobs have been added
but fewer and fewer people are joining
the construction sector and so then it
becomes a question of let it's less
about cantana masada 'kx taking
construction workers jobs and more about
using these products to supplement human
workers because there is a big labor
shortage in u.s. construction and so
that's so it's um it's very one-sided to
say that AI is going to take people's
jobs because there's so much nuance to
that statement that isn't necessarily
correct in popular media as we hear it
today
yeah we're also gonna get old gained a
lot of new jobs which was very exciting
it's also a big issue though because
there's a lot of retraining that needs
to happen for many jobs and it's gonna
be a significant impact on the economy
and it's also not taking into account
wealth inequality and and there we talk
about that a lot on the show so I'll let
that one settle for now maybe we can
revisit it later but something that you
mentioned I think is really important to
bring up is I think a lot of people when
they think about small medium-sized
businesses that most people when it
comes to small media size businesses
including myself I talk about this all
the time that one of the hardest parts
about it is building a team of people
that care about what you're doing as
much as you do and that are as good at
it as you are and there's so many
complex ways to be able to figure that
out but you actually made it clear that
actually the technology like what
technology they end up implementing what
software's they end up implementing in
order to maximize success of their
business is also something that's very
like almost equally kind of difficult
and won't think we think about that as
often no and I think it's because there
I think the concept of buying software
is so divorced from the human experience
of using it and do and more specifically
divorced from who uses it and why so for
example you might not think I need
collaboration software but you probably
think I need a better way to communicate
with my team and so articulating the
reasons why someone would use software
is really important and I that feels
like an obvious thing to say but it's
actually not I think it's not as obvious
as we think of it on either the buyer
side or the vendor side at times and so
the vendors that do get it have a big
advantage yeah and SMBs I get their
software that optimizes their businesses
faster give get bigger advantages
same thing with leveraging AI and all
the different nuances like you said
there's NOP
there's ml there's there's a lot of
different ways to leverage it for the
success of your business so the faster
you that you get on board the more
successful that you'll be so it's really
important to give people consulting as
soon as possible like go and do your
research yourself ask for people's help
quickly look and get at places like get
up to go and see the different
enterprise software ratings and as you
do that process of like coalescing all
this information and going through
hopefully easy-to-use software with good
customer support then you'll be able to
increase the amount of money you're
making increased customer satisfaction
increase efficiency and all your
business processes something that I
thought was interesting is you had
previously done research on skills gaps
in Taiwan and Brazil can teach us about
that sure so as a freelance reporter for
new sites like The Guardian in The Next
Web I covered a variety of technical
topics including digital skills gaps in
markets like Taiwan and Brazil and that
largely focused on
access when you look at those particular
markets a lot of it and a lot of my
reporting was about access to not just
digital skills but digital itself
because there is a sizable part of the
world where people don't have internet
access actually one of the talks today
at the Witte summit was about the skills
gap with women worldwide because a
overwhelming majority of Internet users
globally are men and women are really
getting left behind not just as tech
makers but as users of the technology
and so that was a big part of what I
focused on when I was a doing a report
on digital skills gaps in Taiwan there
was a grassroots organization that would
go around the island trying to bring
these educational opportunities to
people that were in more remote areas
far from Taipei and other cities so that
they could at least experience the
internet and then hopefully gain the
skills that they needed but I think we
have a huge digital skills gap in the US
as well and I think a huge threat with
AI that isn't discussed enough is the
education threat because we have such
demand for jobs but element AI which is
a AI lab based in Montreal estimates
that there are only 22,000 people in the
entire world right now who are qualified
to research AI at a high level and
therefore build it out and if you
contrast that really low number with the
huge not only interest in AI but demand
for services that right there is a huge
problem and the New York Times wrote a
really fascinating feature last fall
about the salaries of people who work in
AI and they talked about how even if you
have a few years of experience if you
get in at the right company you can
easily be making half a million or more
because the skill set is that
valuable in the market right now the
challenge is that a lot of professors at
schools like Carnegie Mellon and
Stanford will leave to go into the into
the industry and that's great except
then who's going to teach these students
like who's going to teach students how
to build machine learning algorithms and
be and become analysts who can help
customers implement AI into their
businesses if there aren't people to
teach these skills that does present an
enormous risk and so if we don't find
ways to consistently upskill people or
help them retrain like through
initiatives like the MIT course that is
a huge challenge because as I mentioned
we're all talking about AI but 22,000
people out of how many people in this
world are only able to really do it per
se right now yes yeah this is so
innocence so such high demand that
there's a struggle between universities
and Industry to take the individuals and
there's these bidding wars going on
between industry as well it's very
ridiculous it's crazy and we let's train
more people to care about to care about
and learn about it and may equalize out
the opportunity for people to get
trained in it ok so I think we'll end up
circling to what were we where we did
what we didn't get to which we'll get to
now and I'll kind of layer that question
in to what you were talking about
regarding socio economics and just being
able to get the opportunity out to more
people no matter what income level
they're at no matter if they're if
they're a female if they're a young girl
or if they are a person of color across
the world whatever that may be through
all those variables how do we increase
the amount of opportunity out for
everybody and the planet here we are at
Witte like how do we empower
different people from around the world
it's a it's a really complicated
question do you mean in terms of using
you know digital tools like the internet
or in terms of helping give people the
skills to join the tech sector and help
build it I'd say probably both yeah both
well so I'm not a development expert so
I can't speak to that aspect of it I
think it I think a few things have to
happen the first is that we need to
prioritize coding at an earlier age I
think kids in preschool should be taught
the basics of coding just like they're
taught the basics of met early math and
reading because the skill set is that
important I mean even in what I do as a
business analyst I know I had my T's
programming language know Microsoft
works at the to scratch like kids can
just really it's like block based coding
for kids no that's great and I think it
because the thing is is in terms of
talking about for let's say the gender
gap in technology
I didn't it's not even that I didn't
want to join the technology sector when
I was in Middle School in high school I
didn't even think it was an option
because nobody told me it was an option
and I think that's an example of how far
we've come even in the last decade
because I just finished serving as a
mentor to girls and technologies Marilyn
chapter so it's a program for high
school girls in grades 9 to 12 to meet
with mentors once a month and talk about
anything from barriers in the industry
to what they're going through trying to
search for colleges and finding the
right colleges to fulfill their majors
and things like that the fact that that
program exists is a is a big thing
because there was nothing like that when
I was their age and I was not their age
that wrote that particular program is
called girls and technology girls in
technology yeah there there are many of
those chapters across the u.s. I believe
so yeah I was involved with the Maryland
chapter and there are many you know
those girls who code there are a lot
more initiatives like that and that's
very different than even a decade ago so
that is a sign of progress in my
and the other thing that I think we need
to do in terms of helping women in
anybody of minority status join the tech
industry is to show the range of skills
that are needed so we absolutely need
more engineers because there is an
enormous need for people and so we
definitely need to get as many women and
people of color and what-have-you into
those technical roles for sure but we
also need people with sociology degrees
to design user interfaces for voice
first technology because engineers are
not the best people to actually script
those conversations and so there's a
range of Technology careers available to
people that have more of a liberal arts
orientation and that is not discussed in
my opinion nearly as often enough and so
educating all students and saying Tech
is for you that if you want it to be
that is a huge part of it as well and
here's the opportunity yeah there's the
right mentors you see it you can be it
yeah all of that yeah we that's been a
reoccurring theme of what we've been
talking about and feels so right like I
love the idea of of getting this out and
there's so many organizations like you
listed that are already doing it that we
need to just continue empowering and
that's why we're here at witty question
about let's run you through a couple
last ones what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world that's I
you know I I would say broadly traveling
to a new place and experiencing it for
the first time so that again that's a
that's a broad one in terms of like what
touches me I'm a words of affirmation
person so getting that from someone I
love is probably the most beautiful
thing in the world mm-hmm yeah you know
just that feeling is
I don't even know it's so hard to put
words into it onto it but it's just
full-body affirmation full-body
validation like you felt like you're
being valued by somebody and you're
hearing that from them like that feels
so incredible it does yeah it's almost
like we need to do more of that as a
civilization like I was just we were
just recently listening to Joe Rogan
talking to Tom Segura and they were on
tour for a long time
and they had never talked to each other
vulnerably about how much they
appreciated each other and it took them
a couple drinks for them to finally be
like like crying a bit and being like I
love you like thank you for everything
and stuff and I just thought that that's
so interesting because otherwise you're
just saying like thank you I appreciate
it but like when are you actually
getting super emotional about it and
telling the person like from your soul
like really so I just thought that was
an interesting comparison which he said
was the most beautiful thing in the
world what do you think about us being
alone in the cosmos I don't think we are
but I don't have enough knowledge to
really build that out further if that
makes sense but I don't think word alone
in the cosmos and then do you think
we're in a simulation no but I do think
it feels like we're living in a bad line
of code and we needed an engineer to fix
it it feel it feels that way I mean it
feel it feels like we're living in some
really buggy code right now and someone
just checked out and was like I'm gonna
go away for a little while bye it's
funny it's like when we talk about
simulation theory we talk about all the
variables that are being calculated at
the same time that once all these rocks
are orbiting stars that have all these
civilizations roaming on them it's
like the ultimate experiment just to
observe and see what happens and so when
you take into account this like a couple
buggy lines of code faulty lines of code
the person that was coding stepped away
for a bit just to see what would unfold
there all these they or they put the
wrong letter in or the wrong variable
and and I mean because that's the thing
about coding right it's one little
mistake can ruin the whole thing so yeah
and so it does feel like we're a little
too close for comfort to that right now
but it's but overall so yes I think it
feels like we're living in a bit of a
simulation right now but it's also
interesting from a tech perspective
because it goes back to consumer
knowledge and consumer trust in these
apps so something I started noticing I
was actually talking about the
simulation theory with two of my friends
and we then started started talking
about something else and I didn't have
my phone out but I started getting
targeted ads that were related to what
we had discussed within a few days and I
said to myself into them I didn't have
my phone out I wasn't googling for that
how am I getting sponsored ads in
Instagram for this thing we discussed
and then what I've since learned is that
a lot of these apps have the microphone
automatically turned on and you have to
go in and turn it off
so when we talk about okay Google there
it goes
just like that you know Mike just turned
on right there or was listening waiting
for you me to say those words
yeah and so that but I think that's even
that's a different example I would say
just because you expect to use Google
and Alexa to give you answers but you
don't expect a lot of other apps to be
listening to you and so the short your
phone's office in a way or yeah or it's
just the screens off it's locked and
it's a way exactly I wonder how often
people experience that targeted ad when
they didn't search for the thing
maybe you search for it on the web maybe
you search for it and a different No so
that's what I always think because it's
easy enough to think okay
there's a digital footprint of me
searching for something so that's why
I'm getting targeted ads that's simple
enough but then again to not when the
digital world's gives you signs that it
was hearing what you were doing when you
were offline that's when it gets a
little creepy absolutely it does and I
and I didn't know that about the the
mics automatically being turned on and
that's an example of where it's
something that has a lot like a in
theory illogical explanation but it's
certainly not the first explanation I
thought of and so then I was sitting
there thinking who's who's watching me
like how to Dana how did they know
washing you through the field of atoms
you and further through what is not even
visible in the third dimension what's
outside of it
the that's the end of privacy's and
hopefully it's for the benefit of
humanity for transparency and for
security and for collaboration hopefully
can also be for very distinct reasons
and I think from the consumer side we
all have to get we have to take more
responsibility about what we're using so
I have a friend who made a conscious
choice not to be on Facebook Instagram
or whatsapp because she wanted to get
out of that ecosystem and first of all
it's not that easy to get out of that
ecosystem for various reasons one of
which is she travels abroad for work
constantly she's in South Africa right
now and if you I mean anybody who has
friends or family abroad knows how
important whatsapp is and so to not be
that's an example of where to not be on
the platform is something I can't
imagine is a signal a telegram and
WeChat and what there's so many of these
services now that are enabling people to
send messages and encrypted ways but you
got to know that is that actually
encrypted is it actually trust it as
your data going to third parties for
development facilitation like there's so
many so much nuance of this and it does
make me wonder we're seeing such I think
there was such an explosion of apps and
digital tools before people started
really
deep diving into these privacy
implications and it does make me wonder
if we're gonna see that recede a little
bit because I think consumers are in the
next five years going to start asking
more questions about their data and how
it's being used before they download
something and it does typically take
something pretty catastrophic like
Facebook's Cambridge analytical scandal
for people to really consider that yeah
and and someone was saying it weenie
yesterday that we're gonna see GDP are
is just the beginning I mean we're gonna
that this is the start of the new normal
because people want to know how their
data is being used but that is also very
market specific so consumers have a lot
more write it rights in the tech world
in Europe Google's right to be forgotten
rule is one example what is that again
so the right to be forgotten is the idea
that that if so if there is a web result
about myself that I don't like and I
live in Germany I could contact Google
and submit basically a request to get
that result deleted from search from
search yes and that is not something at
the moment that is available to users in
the US and so it goes back to cultural
norms and values and yeah and and so but
you you look at the at the EU which is
you know a more heavily regulated body
by and large than the US and so then
political nuance comes into play social
norms come into play and so it's it's a
very complicated issue but by and large
I think people are going to start caring
more about what they download yeah
Lauren this has been a very good
conversation across a couple different
really important topics that I think now
after talking about makes me feel like
I'm more educated about and hopefully
other people are as well I hope so as
well thanks so much for having me thanks
for coming on the show are associated we
have had a good amount of conversation
about about this app market for software
the importance of knowing what's right
for your small medium-sized business the
importance of getting it early getting
in early and testing it out seeing how
it's going
for you so that you can stay at the edge
of what's going on in the world so go
check out get app the links in the bio
also share the content of other people
get them talking about this type of
stuff and also join us subscribe to the
channel goes to comment below join us on
patreon so we can continue doing cool
things like coming around to great
places like witty and highlighting
brilliant leaders from around the world
thanks for tuning in everyone and we'll
catch you soon
you